often here I want to announce that I'm  going to be in Vienna from jun 3rd to  5th I'm there on basically lumber  business which will also take me to  Romania but on the fourth of June in the  morning a number of us are going to meet  at breakfast this will be our Vienna  meet up and I there won't be many people  it could be two or three or four I don't  know but I welcome any of you who are  keen on talking about language and Link  and so forth to come and join us it will  be at the Europa hotel trend Europe I  think it's called hotel in Vienna eight  o'clock on the morning of June the  fourth I will be putting more details on  my blog and I will leave a link to my  blog here in the description underneath  the video so meet up in Vienna june  fourth at the Europa hotel for more  details please follow my blog i'll be  posting something tomorrow about the  meetup i look forward to meeting those  of you who are able to make it to Vienna  June the fourth this vault